this is absolutely incredible so you
know that about six weeks ago we had
what Ron DeSantis described as a
Biblical storm everyone basically said
this was the once in a hundred year
storm in essence a category five
hurricane hit South with Southwest
Florida and just stopped
it basically just stopped on Sanibel and
Captiva into into Fort Myers Beach it
just stopped and wrecked incredible
Carnage on Southwest Florida uh well
we've got a tweet here this is over the
weekend from Florida's voice as to
what's going on just in Governor Ron
DeSantis says Biden administration's
FEMA denied emergency funds request says
state will provide 25 million for
supplies to repair damaged homes
affected by Hurricane Ian yeah you got
that right guys we've given something
like at least 10 billion to Ukraine can
I get a number on that is there even a
number you got a Ukraine calculator
thing
um we have given billions and billions
of dollars to Ukraine we have no
receipts remember I had Rand Paul on
he's just trying to get receipts hey
guys are we buying coffee with this
money or what are we doing with the cash
guys but we can find billions of dollars
but FEMA has cut
cut their help here in the state of art
20.3 billion thank you 20.3 billion
that's the number that we've given
Ukraine we're FEMA is cutting dollars to
Florida these are the leaders of the
United States right now uh however here
in Florida we have America's governor
and he ain't taking [ __ ] from this
Administration uh here he is uh saying
what Florida is going to do to pick up
the slack we're not just going to sit
there
um and and and take no for an answer and
so we're going to figure out what we can
do so that's what we're doing today we
want to cut through bureaucracy we want
to bring relief to impacted Floridians
regardless of whether FEMA wants to be a
part of that so today I'm announcing
Florida will be providing up to 25
million dollars through State funds to
purchase building materials and provide
those materials to verified non-profit
organizations to restore damaged homes
to livable conditions so that Floridians
can move back into their own home
you know the governor actually sounds a
little under the weather himself but
it's not stopping him he is out there
every single day giving press
conferences talking to the press and
doing the right thing you know Florida
has an incredible Surplus an incredible
budget surplus despite having no state
income tax and he's saying hey the feds
it's just obvious guys like you know it
if this hit California if this hit New
York the FED is all in the FED at Joe
Biden Administration does not like Ron
DeSantis they want Florida to be
punished you may remember my interview
from about a month ago with Dennis
Prager where we talked about this during
it was right in the aftermath of the
hurricane and Dennis said that he does
not give him any great pleasure to say
it but he believes that the government
would gladly harm the people of Florida
if that helped them politically so FEMA
what is their job
what is their job it is to help these
disaster areas but in Florida they don't
want to do it so DeSantis is going in
and using the state's money and guess
what this is why he won by 20 points
it's why he'll continue to win and we'll
see what the future holds for him